[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce dernier numéro 9 de la
saison alors on aurait pu revisiter
toute l'actualité il s'est passé il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses depuis
quelques mois mais l actualité actuelle
si je puis dire tellement chargé que
nous avons beaucoup de choses à dire et
pour en parler
alexandra dublanche bonjour bonjour vous
êtes vice présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france et vous êtes adjointe au
maire de sartrouville
merci d'être avec nous judith waintraub
bonjour vous êtes grand reporter au
figaro magazine vous êtes quelqu'un qui
connaît extrêmement bien la vie
politique que vous suivez avec passion
et vous allez nous dire ah non non non
non non mais avec avec avec passion et
avec un savoir formidable merci d'être
avec nous laurent mazaury bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes adjoint au maire des
longs coups à vous allez participer
samedi à une quelque chose important
puisque ce sera l'élection du président
et des vice-présidents de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
vincent couronne bonjour aux
journalistes vous êtes vous êtes de
policers vous êtes vous enseigne la
science politique vous est aussi le
fondateur du collectif s'appelle des
surligneurs c'est à dire que vous
recherchez dans les déclarations
notamment des hommes et des femmes
politiques des propositions qu'il faut
et qui sont parfois déjà dans les lois
ou des propositions qui sont impossibles
à appliquer ses tuteurs de vrais faux de
la politique et jean servat jouannic et
au plateau avec moisson mars bonjour
sans masquer ce qui n'est pas bien pour
un éditeur de de polar oui
gare à quelques minutes à la fin parce
qu'il ya quatre livres que vous publiez
en poche notamment et pour l'été ça va
être absolument formidable aux éditions
la joie dit alors je dis l'actualité est
très chargée on va commencer par le
premier d'entre nous vous d'entre eux
c'est emmanuel macron emmanuel macron la
semaine dernière je disais ainsi que
s'il voulait être réélu il était obligé
de changer de premier ministre il m'a
écouté quand même bien de sa part est-ce
que commencer avec vous dites est ce que
vous pensez que ce remaniement
auxquelles il a procédées changement
promise changement de gouvernement et du
tout réussi deux choses je trouve que
l'équipe n'est pas mal où il a réussi à
créer la surprise avec eric dupond
moretti
rien n'allait fut témoin en tout cas moi
je ne vous avais pas subi au début je
n'ai rien vu deux nuls pas donc il a eu
ce fameux ces faibles entre le disait
nicolas sarkozy qui est indispensable ne
serait-ce que qu'attirer l'attention
il a eu d'ailleurs aussi avec vous ce
que je parle des événements les plus
récents mais il a eu aussi avec jean
castex qui je trouve ça plutôt réussi
ses premiers pas ils parlent clairement
on comprend tout ce qu'il dit n'utilise
pas d'expressions bizarroïde là je sais
tu pas par rapport à edouard philippe
pasqua paiva nouvelle macro on peut la
pression d'être pris pour des imbéciles
ça c'est pour le casting
maintenant on peut parler de tas de
choses de l'equilibre droite par le sang
froid
on y reviendra maintenant moi j'ai un
petit doute par expérience sur les
changements en gros c'est à dire avec
changement de premier ministre
il n'y a pas de changement de politique
on a eu sa sous françois hollande l'a
changé de politique en gardant jean marc
ayrault et et a connu quelques moments
où on avait un peu plus minicipal pour
le remplacer comme manuel valls qui lui
incarné ce virage pro entreprise
beaucoup plus soucieux des questions en
sécurité et du bon les français n'ont
pas compris
qui dit changement colonise
bouleversement dit georges mink
poliquement or là le premier dessin
prévient le patron ça a été pour me dire
notamment à la haye la presse
quotidienne
pas question de faire le jeu alexandra
dublanche sur sur ce gouvernement sur le
changement d'ouvert de mode premier
ministre qui vient de chez vous
d'ailleurs tout à fait écoutez moi je
suis je suis d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit bon la bonne nouvelle c'est
que je trouve que certains ministres
complètement à bout de souffle son parti
et notamment
je pense à christophe castaner d'une
catastrophe en terme de messages aux
forces de l'ordre
je trouve que gérald darmanin fait
plutôt un bon début en communication
maintenant faut voir effectivement la
politique qui va être mené
effectivement je pense que ce changement
de gouvernement c'est beaucoup et c'est
un bon coup de com
c'est bien réussie en terme de coup de
com de casting ça fait aussi diversion
sur le résultat des municipales donc
bien sûr on oublie complètement le
désastre des municipales et après voilà
chez moi pour l'instant castex truc
c'est une bonne une bonne nouvelle parce
que c'est un élu des territoires un élu
rural donc qui je l'espère va pouvoir
renouer ce dialogue avec notamment les
territoires courau
mais est-ce qui va être capable par
exemple de faire ce mouvement de
décentraliser
si on est pas des concentrations qu'on
attend ça voilà on va vraiment être très
attentifs et vigilants à cela notamment
nous côté région ile de france avec
valérie pécresse
donc bon bon coup de com mais
effectivement maintenant faut que ça se
traduise dans les faits sinon ça ne sert
strictement à rien maintenant les
difficultés commencent comme on dit
l'euro l'auront vasari peut-être un mot
sur ce gouvernement
d'abord ce qui a été dit par les deux
précédentes intervenante effectivement
après nous jugerons sur les actes et je
pense également à les effets de bord des
effets collatéraux qui nous ont surpris
avec qui touche
du coup de fait notre territoire la
nomination par exemple les certains
ministres je pense à mahdia et qui m'a
semblé sortir un petit peu de nulle part
ou alors on nomme des milices simplement
parce qu'ils sont des buts et rappelle
quelques uns je pense qu'on a beaucoup
donc ministre arthur et pu faire la
faire après après j'ai fait un petit peu
en un clin d'oeil et je suis assez
d'accord également sur le choix d'eric
dupond-moretti comme le happening
cette opération est une opération très
marketing très marketé mais également je
trouve qu'il ya une forme de clin d'oeil
de provocation dans cette nomination a
nommé quelqu'un qui a pendant
pratiquement plus de 25 ans ou 30 ans
dans toutes ses interventions vilipendé
la magistrature donc ça c'est un premier
point je trouve que ça s'est passé c'est
intéressant à voir mais j'ai également
une inquiétude
même si je partage ce que nous disait
concernant monsieur castex et un homme
issu des territoires mais c'est quand
même aussi un technocrate et une des
parties principales dont nous souffrons
c'est le poids de la technocratie qui va
bien souvent à l'encontre justement de
ce que l'on souhaiterait voir dans les
actes de décentralisation ne veut pas
décentralisé d'un côté et maintenir en
même temps les règles et des règlements
qui écrase à la fois les collectivités
territoriales mais qui écrase aussi nos
entreprises et d'art
c'est une vraie gageure quelqu'un qui
issus de ce profil professionnel biens
professionnels de pouvoir à faire cette
révolution au sein d'un gouvernement a
quasiment moins de 18 mois d'une
élection présidentielle moi il ya de
vrais enjeux
et ce sont de vrais
chiffon rouge pourra être fortement
agité devant le reste de la technocratie
dont nous souffrons beaucoup pour une
meilleur écrit cité dans une situation
la relance va être absolument essentiel
face à la crise qui s'annonce ce qui est
déjà là qui est à nos portes et à la
problématique de la mine qui résulte du
colis je sais je peux ajouter un mot
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que jean castex
est quand même un énarque pour remplacer
un énarque auprès d'un énarque donc là
dessus je je suis d'accord mais après
j'ai foi en voilà dans son lit avec les
territoires je l'espère faut donner sa
chance au produit
c'est pas forcément c'est pas forcément
un mal absolu de sortir de brides de
l'ena jean-charles là je dis non
un petit peu des grains minimum d
expertise ça fait du bien je trouve que
effectivement les là on en dit beaucoup
de mal
c'est très très à la mode de critiquer
mais enfin je veux dire pour l'instant
on voit pas d'autre moyen de deux
formations de certaines élites qui est
appelée à gouverner le pays tout va très
bien
sinon après bien sûr le gouvernement ce
qu'est ce qui est tout à fait
sympathique c'est que les mauvais sont
partis les bons sont restés et les
nouveaux bah oui je veux dire oui il ya
quelquefois des des choix fera me déçoit
amicaux des tas de choses qui font que
effectivement il ya quelques mauvais qui
pourrait rester et là on a l'impression
que emmanuel macron a vraiment fait un
choix pratique séparer de son meilleur
ami enfin son soutien à castaner belhout
et laissa du ministère de l'intérieur
parce que c'est intéressant
edouard philippe était pas si mauvais
moi j'aimais beaucoup
j'avais beaucoup aimé peut-être qui est
peut-être qu'il est assez sain que les
gens enfin que dans un quinquennat on
n'est pas toujours le même président de
la république si ce n'est une certaine
lassitude le même premier ministre et
même promu ni cela parce que le premier
ministre ait et je trouve ça c'est
probablement une des bêtises de du
président chirac d'avoir fait quoi est
ce qu on s idf1 des biens problème
institutionnel peut être par les vassaux
couronne on voit
pour philippe alors certains disent
qu'ils pourraient devenir un rival de
deux des manuels map rond puisqu'il est
populaire on voit la manière sur jean
castex qui est en effet qui est un maire
d'une petite ville m'enfin y'a pas une
derrière politiques qui sont tous les
deux au fonds d'aidé des techniciens
peut-être des des énarques que quand
même comme disait laurent est ce que la
fonction de premier ministre est pas en
train d'évoluer au fond même si
clairement et ça c'est du cdu quand même
modification du terme du mandat des
présents dans le public avec le
quinquennat et l'inversion du calendrier
électoral qui est désormais où on a
désormais une élection initiative qui
intervient après l'élection
présidentielle et donc on a un forcément
on l'avait déjà fait nicolas sarkozy un
peu moins des colonies mais quand même
et surtout aujourd'hui qu'est venu et le
maquereau un renforcement de la
consultation a des pouvoirs à l'elysée
et il ne rien d'étonnant à cela le fait
le problème au pet oreilles qu'on a ici
c'est que si on présidentialise le
régime éveillé faut aller au bout la
logique c'est à dire que et maniema
concentre un certain nombre de pouvoirs
à l'elysée on le voit avec l'ami
nettement de jean le père de jean castex
et puis la déconcentration de ses
conseillers dans les ministères et à
matignon
mais en revanche qu'ils en assument pas
les responsablités derrière ce qu'on
était dans un régime présidentiel
on aurait un pouvoir du certif
extrêmement or en mesure d'arrêter
république en cas de en cas de grave
désaccord politique notamment est donc
là il se roule à plein régime
parlementaire en france avec un premier
ministre qui est censé être nuisible et
assurer la responsabilité politique des
actes ou de la volonté du caudan
république
et ça n'est plus le cas désormais
puisque même l'avant placement d'edouard
philippe ne s'est pas fait sur un
désaccord sur la ligne politique oui
exactement
sur une question purement de stratégie
de stratégie électorale donc donc oui
effectivement le régime se
présidentialise
mais attention il ne devient pas un
régime présidentiel il a bien raison
amplement terre on va dire ultra
présidentialiser je crois que nicolas
sarkozy a soufflé à l'oreille des
manuels macro l'idée de supprimer le
juge prévue le premier ministre fait
notre prochain quinquennat s'il y avait
un prochain quinquennat judith waintraub
est-ce qu'il ya pas quand même derrière
tout ça et on le voit quand même une
solitude absolue du président de la
république jean castex yves à eelv à
l'assemblée il rencontre des députés
encontre des gens il va il va il fait il
va dans des usines etc et on a
l'impression quand même d'un président
de la république est de plus en plus
seules de plus en plus isolé et est-ce
que c'est pas le problème au fond des
institutions de la vème république
mais si les baigneurs au long il faut
faire regroupe les sections sans
éléments après cette marque est revenue
respectives
on a oublié mais quand chirac nomme jean
pierre raffarin certes cette année lui
mais c'est quand même d'abord quelqu'un
extrêmement fidèle et absolument pas
connu nationalement
dominique deville pas encore pire donc
cette évolution là elle est ancienne et
vraiment à raisons institutionnelles
maintenant la solitude
oui on a vu que pendant remaniement il a
essayé de pêcher à gauche et ses prix
des râteaux par les milliards mans au
moins deux valérie à valérie rabault qui
était président qui est ailleurs puisque
la refuser le ministère présidente du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale
ségolène royal dont on s'est moqué mais
qui a effectivement été appelé
ah oui par johanna elle a montré les
messages de jean yves le drian
apparemment emmanuel blanc lui ne l'a
pas appelé derrière donc ça donc donc ça
ça n'a pas marché non ceux d'études
politiques
à gauche même si eric dupond moretti est
marquée à gauche n'a pas sa carte du ps
et puis rétrécissement de sa majorité
propres les marcheurs à l'assemblée donc
au perdu la majorité absolue et il n'a
pas tellement soigner ses alliés qui
sont devenus pourtant indispensable le
modem de françois bayrou françois bayrou
a même dû faire monter le temple bonbons
pour marc fesneau pour que jacqueline
gourault garde le ministère des
territoires
donc oui une extrême solitude mais qui
va avec sa stratégie du coucou puisque
il a été vu en promettant de faire 2 2
et la droite du et la droite et la
gauche
et puis ça a pas mal marché sur la
gauche qui l'a qui l'a complètement
éparpillés pas sauf un enfant qui avait
bien commencé sans lui donc là ce qu'il
essaye de faire en fait c'est d'occuper
tout l'espace à droite alors on va y
revenait justement un alexandre dut
blanche je parlais de jean castex qui
viens devant vous êtes vous êtes un
vérin est ce qu'il n'ya pas comme un
manque de renouvellement mais on aime
bien christian jacob et tout ça bon ils
sont formidables
enfin est ce que il y aurait plus besoin
quand même d'un renouvellement dans
votre mouvement qui fait que des gens
comme edouard philippe comme comme
castex vont avec macron alors qu'ils
auraient pu prendre des fonctions
peut-être aux républicains vous dites
que je suis et l'air mais j'ai quitté un
les élèves
il ya un mauvais set up donc
effectivement je pense que notre famille
politique a toujours eu des difficultés
à faire monter aussi des nouveaux
talents
ce qui est pas du tout cas d'une
personne comme valérie pécresse qui au
contraire va aider et notamment les
jeunes femmes c'est pas une femme qui
ayant souffert ayant un lacet sa vie
politique
elle a dû vraiment se battre elle va pas
faire la ville cela ou à la prochaine
génération voit parfois dans certaines
autres milieux dans certains autres mis
aussi donc voilà c'est quelqu'un qu'on
encourage effectivement et à d'autres
profils auquel je pense qu'on apprécie
ou pas même dans nos départements des
yvelines auxquelles on n'a pas forcément
aussi donner leur chance et qui du coup
sont partis après il qu'ils sont partis
par opportunisme donc ça c'est une autre
question
voilà après faut savoir où on habite
d'où on vient et ce en quoi on croit et
est-ce que ça justifie de partir vers
une autre politique d' emmanuel macron
qui est pas pour moi qui n'est pas une
politique de droite et qui n'est pas
celle que voilà je veux voir pour le
pays
donc ça c'est un autre sujet mais il est
vrai que je pense les républicains ou un
gros travail à faire là dessus en termes
aussi de féminisation quand je vois les
photos des différents comités de ces
rats ça me déprime un petit peu et je
vous aime beaucoup messieurs remet et
donc donc un travail et pierre sur la
solitude c'est vrai on se demande où
sont maintenant les maquereaux nist dans
un gouvernement on voit qu'il ya un
problème de viviez je pense par exemple
de ce que disait laurent mazaury sur le
fait de nommer middle ministre nadia est
sans se rendre compte qu'il ya un petit
problème de suppléants et donc du coup
un risque de perdre la circonscription
je pense que vraiment c'est qu'ils
voient là ils n'ont pas dix mille autres
options et donc ça c'est un bel exemple
de notre anticipation et aussi de manque
de viviez dans les députés on va voir ce
qu'ils vont faire pour les secrétaires
d'état mais effectivement une grande
solitude être parler tout à l'abri de
l'allier et de d2 cette élection par
siècle aura lieu peut-être l'auront
mazaury en toc sentez vous êtes monde
2010 1 vous êtes toujours seul et vous
toujours marrer je voulais dire sur ce
que disait alexandre dut blanche il ya
un phénomène chez les politiques ce site
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
majoritairement des hommes masqués
historiquement ce sont des hommes son
volet tic et on le voit bien dans les
collectivités territoriales on voit bien
les élections municipales
regardez le nombre de molière ce que
j'appelle molière c'est celui qui veut
mourir sur scène c'est à dire qu'on ne
prépare par la succession je m'arrange
pour avoir des gens médiocres et moyens
je suis désolé de le dire
et puis le moment arrivait j'apparais
comme le seul rempart le seul recours
est donc à 88 ans 91 ans je me prépare
je ne m'étends je viens je suis désolé
je caricature déambulateur et puis je
suis étonné de perdre marseille mais je
donne cet exemple mais on en a tellement
autour de nous dans des petites et des
grandes collectivités et effectivement
je partage ce point qu'avec son âme
disait c'est à dire où est la relève
aujourd'hui dans les partis politiques
dans les petits traditionnels il est
c'est très compliqué on le sait bien à
la tête d'un certain ordre deux des
grandes institutions nous avons des gens
qui ne veulent pas parties qui ne
veulent pas céder leur place il est donc
difficile aux nouveaux et la tue je suis
d'accord je rends je rend effectivement
pas j'avais des crises qui a semé et des
bleus voit bien d'avoir poussé avoir
effectivement des femmes mais également
des jeunes issus de la diversité dans un
ensemble de secteurs de l'île de france
et qui sont là mais à un moment donné il
ya ce barrage il ya ceux de baronnies
dans tous les partis ce départ est au ps
il ya souvent des ajouts et bien il n'ya
pas capacité à prendre des
responsabilités et par conséquent et
là-dessus alexandra je comprends leur
opportunisme et un moment donné quand
vous barrez tout le monde et les gens
vont où ils ont ce pouvoir aller pour
vous mettre en oeuvre quand même des
idées qui peuvent être parfois désigné
loca qui sont un peu apolitique qui sont
des idées du quotidien et il faut qu'ils
aient cette petite s'exprimer
c'est un peu là dessus d'ailleurs qu
emmanuel macron à miser quand il a fait
son parti des marcheurs
vous avez beaucoup de gens va susciter
ville mais vous avez aussi beaucoup de
gens qui par opportunisme et pas envie
de faire l'ont rejoint et là dessus et
lui dei comme les autres part de
responsabilité
il faut que nous nous débarrassions avec
tact classes de nos vieux baron d'accord
alors de vos vieux baron ou trouver des
candidats nouveau on va parler justement
du problème de la droite
oui bien sûr c'est bien gentil de toute
organisation humaine dans tout en
alimentation humaine les gens qui sont
en place ont tendance à vouloir empêcher
les autres de leur prendre la place elle
se pose c'est parce que syfy qu'à la
politique
quant aux choix qui serait celui de
valérie pécresse de promouvoir des
jeunes et que des jeunes c'est très très
bien il faut remarquer aussi qu'elle est
partie seule des républicains et que tu
l'as vu par pu partir avec quelques bars
où je pense qu'elle n'aurait pas dit non
dernière remarque effectivement emmanuel
macron a promu des gens qui étaient des
novices en politique
l assemblée c'est globalement une
catastrophe et c'est tellement une
catastrophe qu'il n'a pas plu je le dis
le fréquentant l'assemblée tous les
jours il n'a pas pu constituer un vivier
dans lequel aurait lésé pour constituer
son gouvernement
c'est serrar qui est aussi peut par
exemple de deux présidents de commission
de sages en fait de deux spécialistes de
l'assemblée yvon au gouvernement la ga
évident n'a pas troublé le problème des
novices d' emmanuel macron c'est qu'il
n'y a aucune expérience politique aucune
expérience de d'exécution est de mise en
oeuvre de politiques du terrain il y a
des élus locaux jeune arthur pas 15 ans
de politique
évidemment derrière lui mais qui savent
ce que ça veut dire de mettre en place
en oeuvre et pas seulement dans du
discours des politiques publiques et
donc je pense que c'est ce qui distingue
skis et valérie pécresse de partir seul
j'ai pas eu du tout cette impression là
et elle a des députés des sénateurs
autour d'elle et après elle propose
quelque chose effectivement de différent
et et après on verra comment tout le
monde tout ce beau monde se regroupera
je l'espère pour plus tard mais voilà
j'ai pas du tout eu cette impression là
je vienne au contraire il suffit de
regarder la dernière rentrée politique
du mois d'août dernier pour comparer la
rentrée
l'écart les salles de valérie pécresse à
bord la gaillarde il ya peu à peu près
quatre fois plus de personnes je la joue
peut-être précipité pardon pardon
patrice pour répondre à -20 trop où je
partage ce que vous dite c'est le
principe de ce qu'on appelle l'équité ou
que les américains appellent le fairness
l'inclusivité c'est pas eux s'est pas
d'abord parce que je suis jeune que je
suis pressée d'abord parce que je suis
compétent mais effectivement si je suis
à compétences égales en situation d'y
aller il vaut mieux me choisir en place
et pourquoi pas le baron mais le baron
était extraordinairement convergents il
faut pas le remplacer c'est pareil on
quelqu'un parce que c'est une femme ont
d'abord parce qu'il est compétent et
ensuite c'est pour les pour l'x pour les
personnes issues de la dgst c'est la
même chose dans le personnel politique
c'est pareil effectivement le gage et ce
n'est pas un gage de compétence et vous
avez raison on avait ouvert deux ans je
suis pas revenir sur les propos de ce
détail qu'on a dû supporter d'en passer
des bons moments quand elle parle n faut
vraiment profiter ça fait rire tout le
monde
mais pas eux elle est issue de la
diversité et c'était une femme et qui a
été jeune elle aurait dû être choisi
c'est parce que c'est comment une très
très bonne actrice de campagne
électorale ça j'en suis persuadé mais ça
ne fait pas tellement une porte parole
voilà et donc je pense qu'on est
d'accord c'est d'abord et on touche
technique et entre ensuite à des petites
et et le reste de l'inclusivité bien
comme une donnée supplémentaire
je veux juste apporter cette pression
parce qu'elle me semble important parce
que disait judith c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même un problème de compétences
chez les marcheurs qui était qui était à
la fois une aspiration renouvellement de
la vie politique mais après bon il faut
il faut pouvoir assurer quand on est en
fonctions jean charles
parmi elles la revue s'est toujours pas
l'impression d'entendre les mêmes
critiques quel que soit le personnel
politique on ressort les mêmes analyses
ont dit oui y'a pas de renouvellement
les gens ne se fige civils sont des nuls
quand on les appelle pas on disait
scandaleux tout est confisqué par les
politiques quand on les appelles tu est
une catastrophe
peut-on se remercier les gens qui sont
pas bons comme par exemple la porte
parole comique la grille qui s'en va
c'est très bien il réalise qu'elle est
pas bonne elle s'en va donc arrêtons
toujours de de critiquer sur le principe
il ya des jeunes
il ya des femmes il ya des ans amélie de
montchanin ne paraît pas être la
dernière des abrutis
voilà du julien de normandie etc
il ya toute une pléiade de gens qui
paraissent tout à fait compétents qui
sont là qui sont jeunes qui ont des
hommes les femmes etc
donc arrêtons ces procès d'intention
qu'on pourrait à chaque fois ce chaque
gouvernement sans même regarder la liste
on peut toujours fait dire les mêmes
choses c'est un peu dommage
reconnaissons que de temps en temps il
ya des gens compétents qui sont en bonne
place et puis reconnaissons à maquereau
à edouard philippe
et maintenant à castex de l'idée de
tenter d'essayer de faire bouger les
choses c'est forcément des nouvelles
têtes
il y aura des échecs mais il y aura on
va sûrement avoir de bonnes surprises
par parmi ces nouveaux arrivants alors
ce gouvernement évidemment c'est un
gouvernement en vue de la présidentielle
de 2000 22 justement alexandre dimanche
vous parliez de valérie pécresse
valérie pécresse françois baroin et
xavier bertrand sont les trois dont on
peut penser que il pourrait avoir à être
candidat aux présidentielles de 2022
représenter la droite mais je vais te
demander d'abord vincent pour des piges
vous réagirez après est-ce qu'ils ont
encore une place dans un gouvernement
fasse un gouvernement où on voit jean
castex le maire darmana bachelot est ce
qu'il ya encore une place pour la droite
et pour une droite qui ne soit pas une
droite extrême
vous voulez dire à la place dans la
présidentielle de 2000 22 sks que macro
est pas en train d'aspirer aux faux et
c'est son calcul pour le premier tour en
tout cas la droite classique
si si je pense que c'est ça c'est sa
stratégie a priori et en plus de ça ou
au lendemain des municipales on aurait
pu penser que il se serait un peu plus
déporté vers la gauche profitant un
petit peu delà de la dune vaincre des
grandes villes
ps écolo et fermé maino morici folle
effectivement et continue siphonner de
deux types sonné le marché sur les
plates-bandes de la droite et est ce que
l'espagne est encore disponible pour la
droite
eh bien je crois que le paysage
politique aujourd'hui chez l heure où on
apporte la réponse
c'est à dire que à part effectivement
quelques quelques prétendants il n'y a
pas grand monde après deux ans avant une
présidentielle c'est extrêmement
difficile de faire des pronostics je
crois pas qu'un seul pronostic un seul
des pronostics pour les puis repart mais
pas s'ils étaient avérés
et de deux ans après mais en réalité
peut-être que emmanuel macron ici il
s'attend effectivement un face à face de
gros avec marine le pen qu'il a peur
d'un face à face marine le pen qui
risque d'être en face à face avec un
candidat lr c'est pour ça qu'ils
continuent à marcher vers la droite mais
en réalité pour les pour les municipales
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais
c'est qu'on a beaucoup relativisé le
succès des écologistes aux municipales
dans mes blagues les fous je pense que
ça a provoqué un effet un effet
politique assez assez avec une
déflagration politique au parti
socialiste et écologiste europe ecologie
les verts assez importante qui fait que
psychologiquement aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste envisage de se ranger
derrière les écologistes pour la
présidentielle en 1/2 c'est ce qu'a dit
le premier secrétaire olivier faure et
donc ça mon avis emmanuel macron qui qui
a peur de sa droite en réalité pourrait
peut-être se montrer en 2002 en 2022
face à un candidat commun et qu'en
europe ecologie les verts ps
potentiellement alors je ne trouvais pas
d'accord mais j'ai dit justement vous
avez tout à fait raison sur les
créations d'olivier fort à quel patron
du ps qui colle qui commence la vente
par appartement en revanche côté la
france a soumises mélenchon qui
représente plus
électoralement que parti socialiste est
hors de question de ne pas présenter de
candidat
d'autres au contraire l'émergence des
verts il faut relativiser parce qu'ils
ont pris quelques grandes villes mais en
fait l'ensemble de la france il n'y a
pas de vague verte suis pas en train de
nuit pas de vagues vers l'émergence des
verts est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
magna coûts dans la perspective de la
présidentielle parce que ça lui garantit
de la division à gauche sont des verts
de gauche sa garantie division entre
entre les verts et la france à 6
alexandra dublanche suspension alors on
va on va peut-être parler
de la présence des verbes et peut-être
sur est ce que est ce qu'il ya encore
une place pour un candidat que vous
souhaiteriez je pense que vous
soutiendriez de la droite classique aux
présidentielles évidemment et je
l'espère bien ce que dit vincent
couronne
on parle beaucoup de de casting encore
une fois mais en termes de politique je
cependant je pense qu'il ya un vrai
créneau pour la droite
on va voir notamment sur sur le régalien
sur tout ce qui est laïcité et l'anti
communautarisme où il ya une vraie vraie
opposition de de vue entre ce
gouvernement est ce que la droite peut
proposer alors gérald darmanin à un
discours là beaucoup plus fort déjà dès
ses premiers jours mais on va voir
encore une fois si ça se traduit dans
les faits puisque la cette majorité en
marche fort bien à gauche quand même sur
c'est sur ces sujets il ya aussi je
pense par exemple sur les prisons pareil
avec du beau monde est petit nous on
n'est pas trop dans l'optique de vider
les prisons et ce qui est ce qui est
annoncé ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
présent donc là dessus je pense que s'il
ya des vrais clash et après encore une
fois toujours je prendrai l'exemple
aussi peut-être de l'écologie cette
opposition entre ce qui est dit ce qui
est fait je prendrai deux exemples je
m'occupe de l'agriculture à la région
ile-de-france grandes régions agricoles
n'est ce pas et par exemple le bio il ya
beaucoup de discours le bio le bio le
gouvernement et voilà à porter du bio
bon bah qui se désengage des aides pour
les agriculteurs au bios et ses 7,7 et à
ce gouvernement là et donc c'est la
région qui sont obligés de prendre la
suite
le plan de relance qui se veut
écologique et solidaire donc voilà on
met 15 milliards dans l'hérault nautique
8 milliards dans l'automobile et je m'en
réjouis et pour notre département
notamment qui est très industrielle mais
après on refuse d'aider les transports
publics du quotidien qui sont ce qu'il
ya de plus écologiques et de solidaire
puisque accessible à tous heures et
d'aidé à hauteur de bien lui signares
d'euros et de france mobilité donc il ya
beaucoup de choses comme ça et c'est
beaucoup une politique aussi de taxation
qui est plus ancrée
à gauche de l'échiquier politique alors
que nous on est plus dans l'incitation
avec des aides pour aider
et d'ailleurs la taxe et les taxations
c'est ce qui a déclenché un mouvement
comme les gilet jaune notamment
donc il ya beaucoup de choses sur
lesquelles on n'est pas d'accord est
effectivement aussi tout ce qui est
organisation du millefeuille français
des collectivités avec cette volonté de
décentralisation pourquoi on veut de
cette réalisation se fait juste une
histoire de pouvoir
c'est une histoire d efficacité on l'a
très bien vu pendant cette crise qui
étaient plus efficaces et les mères
c'est les régions ces départements c'est
absolument pas l'état même sur des
questions de santé comme qui sont de la
compétence de l'état on l'a vu sur les
masques donc on veut un mouvement et on
va voir s'il va arriver on encore une
fois qu'il ne soit pas de
déconcentration en donnant plus de
pouvoirs aux préfets dans les
départements met donc à l'état mais de
décentralisation faire confiance aux
collectivités à ceux qui sont plus
proches du terrain et qui sont le plus
capable d'adapter des politiques aux
réalités du terrain on va pas porter la
même politique en seine et marne ou à la
défense
c'est évident et pour cela il faut une
bonne connaissance du terrain donc il ya
énormément d'enjeux sur lesquels on est
on est en compétition et il ya des
enjeux
enfin il ya des politiques sur lesquels
on se retrouve et tant mieux
et si ça va dans le bon sens on l'a
toujours soutenu en tout cas avec
valérie pécresse
mais il ya des grands points de blocage
concerne la jolie je suis toujours
étonné par le fait de vouloir trouver un
candidat à droite un candidat ventes ont
un président de centre-droit et c'est
très bien comme ça il n'y a pas besoin
d'autres plus d'autres personnes
d'autres candidats ensuite devant l'ailé
les trois personnes qu'on a vues soit
baroin pécresse ou xavier bertand c'est
en tout cas pour pour baroin et xavier
bertrand et paraissent tout à fait
premier ministrable compatible avec avec
un maquereau président une deuxième fois
valérie pécresse pourquoi pas qu'elle
ait l'air très bien la région peut-être
que la maman se dit voilà c'est bien
aussi de rester là mais enfin en tout
cas voilà tous les trois ce serait tout
à fait ils se voient pas de d'opposition
et je pense que c'est un peu curieux de
la question d'opposition aux questions
de places ce qui est lui placé mais
c'est peut-être ça qui est en train de
tuer les républicains c'est à dire que
plutôt que deux
j'essayais de de se dire qu'est ce qu'il
ya de bien chez makro et c'est quand on
est dans le derby il va falloir qu'on se
démarque absolument et comment se
démarquer de quelqu'un qui pense qu
est-ce qui pensent que non mais j'ai dis
pas que c'est ce que vous avez dit vous
mais en règle générale est toujours là
en train de dire bon la droite doivent
de doivent se réinventer bien peu dire
que les républicains ne n'essaye pas de
de se droitiser comme deux connus comme
des fous de macron féfé fait très bien
le job c'est à dire je la moitié des
français considèrent que c'est un
président de centre-droit et voilà je
veux dire bon bah c'est peut-être
dommage pour les gens qui avaient un
alors sur les énormes succès il ya des
succès électoraux qui compte beaucoup
lire après que nous existons appart ans
oui mais après vous comparaissez
comparables on sait très bien que la 83
% des mères ont été réélus il fallait
pas s'attendre c'est vraiment de
l'acharnement contre macron que de dire
il ya perdu les élections municipales
ok ça ça passe ça pète et un conseils
municipaux c'est comme si moi je me
disais je vais courir un marathon et
marathon mais je me fixe l'objectif pas
km enfin 4g la république on mange tous
face à grand chose
l'europe autorise est apprécié tout
centre-droit c'est vraisemblablement à
101 candidats qui aujourd'hui est de 2
venus de centre-droit mais moi pas d'où
il vient et je rappelle quand même qu'il
était à l'elysée et qui là c'est une
grosse partie de la politique de
françois hollande ou moins de succès est
d'ailleurs plutôt moins pendant un
certain temps et un peu plus quand il
était sur le point de partir donc qu'ils
viennent de la gauche et qui les pins
qui soient passées à droite à revault
l'ontt et de carrière c'est assez
classique qui ont deux choses pour un
jeu wii je suis assez d'accord avec
monsieur adjani là-dessus où il dit mais
néanmoins on empêche effectivement que
la droite mais là le centre bien entendu
devra soutenir et présenter un candidat
parce que je vais prendre un exemple
madame blanche on attendait un tout
petit peu râlant de la petite et prison
puisque je parlais de maître
dupond-moretti hier sa première visite a
été à fresnes
personnellement j'ai été choqué c'est
pas ma politique d'entendre quel immense
qui a été dire que dirais tu en as
prison à la bonne nouvelle grâce au peu
vide nous avons pu élargir un maximum de
prisonniers et du coup il ya plus de
sueur densité carcérale à fresnes et les
cas c'est que ce que que ce genre de
réjouissement toutefois avoir de nous
dire c'est super nous avons élargi des
délinquants moi mon objectif je suis
très claire et d'ailleurs pour le coup
en deuxième partie j'avais soutenu la
candidature de françois fillon après
avoir soutenu celle de canal j p en
première partie
c'était le programme d'ouvertures de
nouvelles places de prison parce que
puisqu'on parle de soutenir par exemple
les policiers ou moins des amis
policiers quand il arrête quelqu'un je
lui enfoncer des portes ouvertes mais au
bout de 24 ou 48 heures ils sont dehors
et je les entends dire oui mais les
magistrats estiment judiciaire mais
soyons honnêtes des uns seront toujours
été donnée par le parquet sur des quotas
de personnes à mettre en prison parce
que il n'y a pas de place pour les
accueillir
c'est une logique j'en suis désolé
budgétaire c'est pas choquant mais si on
veut lutter contre l'insécurité dans les
rues concrètement il faut un moment
donné effectivement faire comprendre à
des gens qui doit être puni le parcours
de ces différents thèmes passe par pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles de la
prison vers les mêmes à ces noms-là
taubira avec les peines de 10 au moins
deux hommes dames et 7,8 et donc il faut
des places de prison sinon on peut
toujours à des policiers leur permettre
d'arrêter les gens et puis on peut les
mettre en guerre mais une partie de la
magistrature de toute façon va fa les
moyens de d2 de mettre en prison suis
désolé les délinquants donc il ya la
nécessité d'avoir un candidat c'est là
qu'ils sont aussi des valeurs du respect
de la rue appel que qu on arrête des
gens qui ne respectent pas la loi en
couleurs des valeurs républicaines et
que ces valeurs républicaines pour le
coup elle ne sont ni de droite ni de
gauche qui suit la révolution française
donc à un moment donné oui il faut un
candidat de droite et du sens aux
attaques ont fait le bien le club sur
certains sujets et comme le disait même
blanc où étaient les autres
nous soutenons quand ces mesures nous
semblent bonnes pour acquérir de bonnes
mesures
et aussi vous avez raison madame blanche
toute cette hypocrisie sur le bio
heureux que vous les trouvez pas ce que
c'est humyo quotidien et le bio auront
été sont les collectivités territoriales
qui le font quand elle passe des marchés
publics pour les comme ces sept comment
acquis
la majeure partie le volume et donc
wizzgo un candidat de droite et du
centre aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
c'est plus une supplique tout à fait sûr
que françois fillon plus soit pour
l'exécution des peines
[Musique]
judith et les gens savent pas s'ils
étaient mis le doigt sur les deux
questions qui ne permettent pas
d'identifier les républicains et manuel
pas qu'on la sécurité laurent mazaury en
a parlé
brillamment je ne revienne pas dessus
mais effectivement à la raison il ya
aussi la laïcité
gérald darmanin qui est désormais
ministre des cultes puisque le ministre
de l'intérieur s'est illustré en 2015
après les attentats en disant son
opposition à ce qu'il a appelé la
laïcité punitive
je ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'elle a ni
laïcité punitif je suis contre la
laïcité avec adjectif
il a aussi proposé une réforme avec
l'islam spots sur le modèle des mois
j'ai perdu le mot sur le sur le sur
l'organisation de l'islam en france il a
été prise à partie hier au sénat
d'ailleurs un actif et apartés ans était
très intéressant par jacqueline eustache
brinio qui considère la sénatrice les
républicains du val d'oise ex maire de
saint gratien où elle s'est battue où
elle était vraiment persécutés notamment
par des salafistes un concordat voilà le
beau que je cherche une échappée il
voulait encore lui accorda avec l'islam
et d'orignaux qui publie aujourd'hui un
rapport extrêmement intéressant sur la
reconstitution d'écosystèmes islamistes
dans certains quartiers de france
a causé une question hier à gérald
darmanin enseignants et l ufr envoyer
sur les roses sur le thème vous
caricaturez un peu comme jean charles
lajoie nuit droitisation c'est bien de
sauter c'est bien de sauter sur sa
chaise en disant je suis laïc je suis
d'avis que je suis laïc mais là encore
il faut des preuves alors ayant dit
qu'alexandra du blanche avait
parfaitement raison je suis obligé
d'ajouter que malheureusement j'ai peur
que les français soient moins sensibles
que nous deux en tout cas elle ce genre
de problématique
oui c'est toujours la question de la
place mais mais et pour finir il me
semble
en gros il y aura une place pour un
candidat droite si emmanuel macron
échoue et seulement si les jours mais
cela dit emmanuel macron avec des mots
forts sur sur ben sur le communautarisme
nous pensons la laïcité nous parce que -
non on l'attend toujours
et puis les mots celui qui a eu des mots
ces gens qui respectent pas ce que c'est
c'est appréciable de l'entente de m
l'autorité et la laïcité
parmi les avec la responsabilité dans le
triptyque des valeurs qui étaient ces
valeurs de référence mais ce ne sont des
mots pour l'instant jean-charles oui
alors je voulais juste venir un petit
peu sur ce qu'avait dit le rang mazaury
alors d'abord c'est quand même sous
vaqueront que maintenant les peines de
prison sont exécutés exécutable après un
an tout condamnation à plus d'un an
alors qu'avant c'étaient deux ans donc
ça c'est quand même pas c'est une mesure
que la droite aurait tout à fait pu
proposer 10 et 15 et qu'elle ne peut
qu'accepter d'une part et deuxièmement
c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens ont été
élargis c'est des gens qui étaient en
fin de peine et que tu as fait d'accord
avec laurent il faut au contraire il
faut construire les places de prison à
l'évidence mais les cdd des prévenus à 4
par cellule dormir par terre dans des
cellules de 9 m² c'est une indignité
absolue donc on est libéré et contraire
à la voulu élargir à la halle a voulu
garder les prévenus et comme elle s'y
est mal pris je parle de nicole
belloubet sa décision
n'a pas été appliquée à fait tout la
verse on est d'accord
ce sont ces même plus la peine de faire
le procès de louvain qui était d'une
élite est consternante met donc dans les
faits le problème c'est alors si on va
aborder ce problème et c'est quand même
le propre du budget de la justice qu'il
quand même absolument scandaleux enfin
on est ronde et dans les derniers pas
dans le budget de la justice en france
c'est on voit bien comment les
magistrats sont nous n'ont pas de moyens
pour travailler comme moi ils sont
submergés par les a faits sont très bien
comment les prisons sont sur occupés en
effet et alors c'est vrai que le coc
vite finalement ça va une bonne nouvelle
pour les prisons parce que du coup bah
on est on est à 100 % d'occupation
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
prisons le lac au vide mais c'est une
catastrophe pour les catastrophes pour
la justice parce que la justice s'est
quasiment arrêté pendant deux mois et
demi donc il y avait déjà un engorgement
total de tous les tribunaux et là il ya
des procès qui vont qui sont remis à un
an et demi après la lune
une défaite et une défaillance de la
justice effectivement parce que ça fait
des années que le budget ridicule qu'il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut et que s'il
faut qu'on se déplace de prison il faut
des magistrats il faut plus de moyens
c'est u c'est une évidence
alors vincent couronne on va revenir à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
à dire la la ce que vous appelez vous la
poussée verte c'est vrai dans les
grandes villes bordeaux lyon
strasbourg notamment est-ce que pardon
donc quelqu'un est à voter est ce que
est ce que je dis tu disais c'est au
fond c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
macron parce que ça va diviser la gauche
est ce que ma croûte se perdrait pas
aller chercher un électorat qui est
quand même extrêmement disparates ya
dans les verts il ya des il ya des gens
de gauche qui a des libéraux il ya des
antilles croissance il ya et il y à déjà
qu'ils ont pour la croissance verte
c'est un électorat très compliqué à à
capter non oui bon je pense qu'ils en
capte déjà une partie parce que nous ne
serait ce que par l'ailé comment dire
les verts qu'il arriva les écologistes
qu'il arrive à capter aussi au
gouvernement la nomination par barack
donc il y en a un exemple mais je trouve
quand même que c'est vrai effectivement
il peut même il faut relativiser cette
victoire des verts aux municipales de
jus d'accord ils n'ont pris que quelques
grandes villes
huit grandes villes en france et en
revanche je pense vraiment que sur le
mondial se sent prêt des petites villes
qu'ils ont prises ce sont quand même des
débiles comme porto comme lyon caen
strasbourg etc
si on fait le compte des huitièmes les
verts ont remporté ça représente 1,7
million d'habitants en france d'accord
si on y rajoute à ça des villes
comment dire remportez pas regardé par
la gauche avec une alliée importante
avec les écolos c'est à marseille ou à
paris on arrive à un quasiment 5
millions d'habitants
en réalité en fait ce que ces
municipales provoque même si c'est une
petite partie de l'électorat français
c'est quand même 10 % du corps électoral
et au final ça va donner une visibilité
aux écologistes et surtout ce qu'il faut
retenir mon avis est que les écolos ont
regagné systématiquement grâce à des
alliances avec les avec la victoire et
sur une partie de la gauche et que ça
peut ça peut enclencher dynamique pour
la présidentielle a assuré que si on
regarde les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
d'intentions de vote ces rats
socialistes ça pèse pas grand chose à
terra mais tout est question ici de
dynamique et à mon avis c'était
municipal même si encore une fois les
écolos n'ont pas vos portes et
d'un point de vue du suffrage ces
élections municipales d'un point de vue
symbolique et médiatique force est de
constater que s'enclenche une dynamique
alors voir des usines j'ai une
explication qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut
mais j'ai l'impression que on annonce
partout 1-1 2e tour macron le pen pour
2022 et quand on regarde les sondages
les français n'en veulent pas et moi
c'est mon impression c'est qu'ils
cherchent une alternative assets à ce
combat annoncé d' avance et que
peut-être il le cherche chez les verts
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
les uns et les autres minutes
c'est effectivement une hypothèse de
travail intéressante c'est vrai que les
français sont peu intéressés par duel le
pen macron le match retour il a pris 2
les cartes parce que et heureusement en
france c'est quand même toujours un
match retour que ce soit chirac ou
maquereau qui s'est emporté qui est
emporté 2 ac grandement parle par le
candidat démocrate
mais effectivement peut-être d'abord
qu'un jour ça pourrait basculer c'est
quand même extrêmement dangereux mais
deuxièmement c'est vrai que le discours
politique et le débat politique
gagnerait sûrement entre entre deux
personnes qui ce pourrait être macro et
un candidat - vert et le plus sérieux
schiste et c'est ça c'est une certitude
dans quels cas va intervenir si oui ma
patrie j'avais peut-être quelque chose à
dire c'est je vais relancer des bars et
quand vous dites les france impression
que les français ont envie moi j'ai
l'impression que les médias ou vie et
que encore une fois si nous nous
mettions à parler autant tout d'un coup
de jeu faire exprès de marine le pen que
nous barbe ont toutes les deux minutes
même si c'est justifié du réchauffement
éthique et des risques écologiques je
pense que les français vous dirais que
tout bien considéré il voit l'arbitrage
entre my aim et emmanuel macron la
réalité c'est que malheureusement et
surtout d'essentiel pour ça je parlais
tout à l'heure des programmes dans les
petits sauf que sauf que à la dernière
minute vous constaterez que c'est
souvent le candide
plus médiatisé le plus beau ou la plus
jolie qui l'emportent parce que ça reste
une option ip personnalisés il en va de
la tendance politique aujourd'hui je
vous assure il nous nous mettons tout
aux antennes de télévision et de radio
expliqué d'aucun estero il va frapper la
surface de la terre et qu'un parti se
crée le parti qui sera contre
l'astéroïde l'emportera je fais exprès
car elle comble trump heist
mais j'essaie de dire quand vous avez un
écosystème qui a effectivement comme
sujet la transition écologique moi j'en
entends toujours beaucoup parlé mais
personne n'a jamais dit explique
d'ailleurs la transition écologique est
bénéfique pour l'économie
ça c'est en général la dépense d'argent
public 1 c'est rarement un business qui
sont morts si par exemple la voiture à
hydrogène
voilà là on arrive on apprécie et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est concret
bizarrement je n'entends pas les
écologistes en parler le pas du
nucléaire on fait tout l'inversé
nous on se transforme en allemand une
ferme notre centrale nucléaire pour
acheter par les structures de personal
qui certes était une centrale
vieillissante
il aurait mieux valu ont construit le
nôtre faire de la provocation jusqu'au
bout elle est achetée l'électricité
allemande produite par d'électricité à
70 cents carbonée voilà mais ça on n'en
parle pas par contre nous tous tu nous
les médias relevaient de dents à ce que
j'ai plaisir à être présent de cette
chaîne vous venez de dire nous parlons
du mans toutes les minutes d'écologie
regardez les appels d'offres s'est
désolé le dit nous avons à peu près 30%
des notes aujourd'hui dans les appels
aux marchés publics qui parle d'écologie
tout le monde dit satisfait ou que les
français patrice ne pense pas envie à
l'écologie au moment de voter et en
partie avec nous les médias sur internet
sur le digital
je lance pas fait exprès parce que je
pense que nous faisons beaucoup
l'élection aux gens quand je dis les
français ne veulent pas c'est les
sondages qui montrent qu'ils veulent pas
te et j'ai déjà eu près non seulement
les médias barbe d'or et moi j'essaye de
parler de la pile à combustible à chaque
pas chaque je m'interrogeais sur ces
sujets là mais avec mes petits bras
évidemment ça ne permet pas de
réorienter le débat mais le disco
écologique qui a gagné les grandes
villes aux municipales et tel discours
écologique décroissant anti-progrès
absolument catastrophique mais force est
de constater que l'autre disco ce matin
par exemple bruno le maire était sur une
rame
il a parlé du grand plan et hydrogène en
avant il a parlé de choses comme ça mais
il est il est à des rares et
malheureusement les hommes politiques
sont plutôt dans l'ensemble des
magouilles sur le sujet je pense en
premier lieu à emmanuel macron encourage
l'écologisme décroissant oui on a vu
avec la avec la place voyez pas là et
moi j'ai un peu catastrophique
exactement juste je suis tout à fait
d'accord que l'écologie qui a gagné ses
grandes villes d'ailleurs c'est que des
métropoles s'est passé loin d'être le
cas ailleurs en france et ça aussi faut
faire très attention
pr l'écologie qui soit aussi sociale est
accessible à tous ça on y tient vraiment
nous beaucoup c'est vraiment cette
idéologie de la décroissance
l'interdiction en gros faut interdire de
circuler pour que les voitures soient
propres
arrêtez de construire pour que les
logements soient sol et nous on est
plutôt dans une écologie concret avec
des maires au quotidien des fonds de
l'écologie qu'henri finances des jardins
partagés du compost c'est du très
concret et peut-être qu'ils le qu'il ne
placarde pas dans un dans un froid même
si beaucoup on a quand même parlé mais
c'est au quotidien que sur toute la
toutes leurs actions est sûre pour
revenir sur la convention citoyenne et
pécresse a reçu hier par exemple tous
les franciliens de cette convention
citoyenne
voilà on a analysé toutes les
confessions et des choses il ya des
choses à reprendre sortir du usage de la
voiture en solo c'est en ile de france
vous passez à deux personnes par voiture
au lieu de 1,1 à aujourd'hui vous
arrêter vous stoppez les bouchons donc
il ya vraiment du travail à faire là
dessus ce pour ça que mon finance toutes
les toutes les applis de covoiturage on
offre le covoiturage en grève était tard
pour essayer d'inciter davantage à des
choses comme ça la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols bien
évidemment donc elle est très bonne
chose mais après ce nom qu'on s'est
rendu compte dans ses dialogues avec les
citoyens hier c'est qu' il n'avait pas
du tout été challenge est un fin il
avait une vision très unique
d'un seul côté de chaque problème et
donc il n'y avait pas eu du tout de
dialogues d'une autre vision et aussi du
de la confrontation à la réalité
orienté en compte son plein on pouvait
dire il ya cette histoire d'orientation
et de biesme il ya aussi cette histoire
de ne pas être du tout dans la réalité
quand on dit faut piétonniser tous les
centres villes alors comment on fait ça
veut dire fou faire des voies de
contournement et donc des routes autour
du délit donc et ils sont pas allés
jusque là dans ses réflexions donc c'est
ça qui est un peu problématique c'est
qu'il faut discuter concrètement de
cette écologie et dès qu'on passe à
l'opérationnalité des choses ça devient
beaucoup plus compliqué mais il faut le
faire et je pense qu'il ya d'ailleurs
des choses quand même à reprendre
évidemment dans cette convention
citoyenne mais en la confrontant la
réalité pardon parce qu'ils grignotent
assez peu tout je voudrais quand même
qu'on aborde vous en avait parlé
la question de nadia qui a été nommé
donc ministre délégué à la ville qui
était député de la 12e circonscription
des yvelines ses dires de trappes et
cette nomination va provoquer une
élection partielle au mois de septembre
puisque le suppléant de madame et ne
pouvaient pas elle a démissioné puisque
son suppléant et est impliqué dans une
affaire de drogue
donc est ce que quand ils ont pris la
décision de la nommer est ce qu'à votre
avis quand ils ont pris la décision de
la nommer ministre ils savent et ils
pensent et ils ont réalisé qu'il y
allait avoir une élection partielle
parce que là il ya un gros risque la
majorité est vrai mais déjà perdu la
majorité absolue
là il ya un risque aussi la de perdre
encore un siège exactement et je pense
c'est laura mazauric qu'il ait dit non
je pense qu'ils ont pas du tout ils ont
pas du tout envisagé cela ils ont ainsi
son 10e et luttera pour va la mettre à
la politique de la ville
voilà ça peut être ça retrouver le voilà
et donc nous a effectivement il ya un
gros risque pour eux de perdre cette
circonscription parce qu'en plus on a un
très bon candidat qui othman deux roues
et qui je l'espère qui a tout mon
soutien en tout cas pour être candidat
c'est quand même bon donc je précise
quand même que pierre bédier a dit qu
une bonne frousse était déclarée un
petit peu vite qui serait pas forcément
pour lui dans la nasse roux a quand même
de deux quasiment remporté la ville de
trappes à 160 voix près
à droite enfin je peux si vous réalisez
bien donc à 160 vous après avec des
pratiques un peu douteuse du candidat
qui ait gagné
donc il a toute la légitimité pour
partir sur 7 sur cette élection là il a
le soutien de de monsieur fourgous
l'ancien l'ancien député d'autres maires
de la circonscription et je pense
vraiment qu'il peut remporter cette
circonscription donc oui erreur majeure
des agnelles macron là-dessus vitro que
vous pensez à un retour de benoît hamon
votre ami moins courues jeu
d'information que je peux avoir je sais
qu'il a été contacté il a répondu en
premier qu'il n'irait pas mais je ne
suis plus très ne soit pas et vante le
point de changer d'avis ce sont les
bruits claude verneau désolé qu'ils ne
sont pas mais c'est intéressant quand
même heure dans la manière dont se fait
un remaniement c'est à dire qu'on a
quand même l'impression qu'il ya des
décisions qui se prennent vraiment à la
dernière minute et sans envisager toutes
les conséquences qu'elles peuvent avoir
la première décision de ce type là c'est
quand même de celle de promouvoir gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur parce qu'en fait
tout était bouclé c'est dans les
dernières 24 heures aux dernières 48
heures que gérald darmanin débat c'est
très simple
moi si on me donne pas l'intérieur je
retourne
alors quoi c'était bancaire qui devait y
aller pardon ces bloqueurs qui devait
être une liste de l'intérieur nous
parler de la provision c'en est une
belle papa de ma part de gérald darmanin
apparemment mais c'est pour ça que c'est
toujours assez amusant les remaniements
on a l'impression que ça peut être
répond c'est d'abord c'est tout ça et il
ya toujours des rebondissements au
dernier moment merci à tous alors avant
de notre kit est bien géré on va faire
quelques conseils de lecture de vos
éditions sandra martin aux dernières
escales
voilà je décroche alors c'est tout et
c'est une nouvelle collection de poche
et qu'à petites qui sont sortis pour les
pour les grandes vacances pour le pour
l'été mais très bon travail et unis vont
robin c'est presque un programme
électoral de la yaris cavaliers travail
était absolument bonne fiction de la
presse et pas pour qu'ils s'y mettent
pour les merveilles et puis du passé
faisons table rase et faisons table rase
et dont l'élection présidentielle 2022
comme tout le monde
une collection très m'as crânienne
l'absolu mais en fait pas du tout quand
on la lit merci merci beaucoup alexander
dublanche judith waintraub laurent
basauri vincent couronne et jean charles
lajoie lee et puis bonnes vacances pour
va se retrouver à la rentrée si vous le
voulez bien
merci à tous
[Musique]